[Music]
cool so today on the podcast we have
mike hanks de Becque if you have any
extensive knowledge and experience in
firearms military and most recently the
cannabis business so how did you get
started in all this it's been really an
interesting journey with this whole
thing it initially started with a friend
of mine who was a special operations out
of MacDill Air Force Base mm-hmm
suffering from PTSD and he'd 24 years of
honorable service to the country and
ended up having some problems got
physical with his wife one night was
arrested for domestic violence we tried
to get a grip as to what was going on
again this guy's special operations guys
they don't touch their wives they're not
abusive individuals right and so we
started to figure out that he was on 14
different type of psychotropic drugs
that the VA was giving him and sisal
what is psychotropic drugs these are
drugs that actually helped them with
deal with PTSD with regards to actually
altering their moods okay so the biggest
problems obviously sleep with a lot of
these guys they're just not getting good
sleep right if you're Special Operations
guy you're used to being the guy that
goes and helps everybody you don't used
to ask him for help right now these guys
just don't go down that road and after
this became apparent that was something
wrong
I said Alan what is going on he said
listen min the last the last medicines
that the VA sent me what it said it said
may have or may create anal leakage anal
leakage anal leakage I think I'm 44
years old and I've got to [ __ ] my pants
because of so it became a real issue so
we started to look at the what's really
going on with him at the same time I saw
a program on TV called vice land yeah
and they were it was a dealing with a
security group in the cannabis business
out in Denver Colorado and these were
all combat vets so our combat vets are
suffering from PTSD in the worst way
we're losing 20 to 22 guys a day 20 to
honorably charge discharged well-meaning
human beings they're coming out into the
world and committing suicide if they
come out of everyday everyday so when
you start to look at these numbers that
is not acceptable we decided that we
were going to send how and out to Denver
Colorado to actually meet with I
actually called the CEO of the company
up and spoke him on the phone
told what our dilemma was that the
answer wasn't to go out and medicate or
to start smoking cannabis the message
was to get out here and talk to other
brothers who have been in combat who
understand what you're going through and
can identify what's happening so after
about four or five days of trying to
convince him to go out he decided to go
out we put him on a plane threw him out
there and he was out there for about two
weeks and again all the individuals they
hire out they're combat vets mm-hmm so
he had decided after about a two-week
period that he was gonna try to medicate
this is an individual who'd been on five
different operations looking for Osama
bin Laden in the Middle East and was
very full of bravado the nights that he
would go on his operation saying hey
tonight's night we're gonna kill this
guy right the night that he was getting
ready to medicate the first time he was
absolutely terrified and I had to remind
him that listen marijuana never killed
anybody
nobody overdoses on marijuana you can't
impossible I said we didn't send you out
there this is not about trying cannabis
or marijuana this is about going out
there and kind of find a center spot
that you're in a better place mm-hmm so
after about 45 minutes of talking he
decided that he was going to medicate
that night they were all they were
camping outdoors and he called me at 8
o'clock the next morning and with the
realization that was the first time in
six years he had slept through the night
Wow so we are as we start to identify
problems do really with sleeping I mean
listen when you catch prisoners of war
the first thing you wanna do is deprive
them of sleep three days of no sleep
will kill you
right so you can imagine if you're not
sleeping well through the night having
these challenges of these problems so we
kind of begin to identify what was going
on with Alan now he is you know he
remarried his wife he's living out there
again he's fully functional I'm a full
blown on advocate now for cannabis and
that all that side of it right
understand that these guys are like I
say we're losing 20 to a day
unacceptable it's changed his life
around completely it's impossible to
overdose on cannabis you can't do it
there's been no lung infections cancers
I've looked I've spoke to medical
professionals now here in the state of
Florida for last five years as we look
at the legalization of cannabis here in
Florida right obviously because it's
still federally illegal as a Schedule
one drug the VA is very very slow to
react to this whole process so again the
whole hard car
background the understanding of what
we're trying to do is time to finish to
the forefront we hire nothing but combat
vets we're at world-class asset
protection and transportation group we
drive up armored vehicles on they're
very discreet we look for combat vets
because obviously this is the kind of
experiences they were having overseas so
we have a purpose we have a function
there is somewhat of danger involved
with regards to what we actually do but
it's scheduled so by bringing other vets
into the picture these guys now have
there's camaraderie and there's the
bravado and all that they were missing
in the service so what what has been
what has been like the latest research
or where is this country at in regards
to treating PTSD like what has been like
the most the most recent science on and
her studies on it
I think listen when we start looking at
really at what's going on with PTSD and
you start looking at combat vets
especially the challenges are this
you're overseas you're in an environment
where you're getting mortared every day
or shot at with the possibilities you've
got vehicle-borne IEDs that are going
off every day is a day that's full of
adventure and when you live in such a
high plateau we are literally you know
listen you hear a boom go off in the
background and your adrenaline starts to
run you know instantly that something's
going on somewhere in town so this goes
on every single day so if you do this
for about 12-month period
what happens is you become used to kind
of living at that higher level so when
you come home I'll give you an example I
think we could talk about this one of
the guys we have as a former scout
sniper great guy to look at the guy
you'd never realized that this guy
suffers from PTSD in such a scout sniper
what do you mean by that he's actually a
sniper in the Marine Corps okay
been in for eight years saw five combat
tours I'm not going to get into the
number of individual kills these guys
have now let me just say this too for
the record we vet every every vet that
comes to work with it we vet them out we
make sure they are exactly who they say
they are we look at their DD 214 s we're
verifying who these guys are and you
must be a combat but if you work for
hard car so as we start looking at these
individuals and start peeling back the
layers um I saw he was a scout sniper I
knew he had deployed to Iraq didn't
realize how many times he'd actually
deployed to Iraq
and then we started talking about the
number of kills that he had actually
accomplished while he was there which
was extraordinary and I'm thinking to
myself what do you do with a guy like
this when he comes back what'd he do
with the Navy SEAL who's got 5 or 6
tours under his belt
he's been trained he's that millions of
dollars instilled upon him or her to be
the special operations person why not
bring them back here and give them a
chance to use us all that knowledge base
they've learned there's millions and
millions of dollars they pulled up on
right so for us it's been a big push in
that whole direction to make sure we're
getting these guys kind of back again to
a listen it's not real dangerous but
obviously there's dangers involved
there's robberies and theft that going
all the time in California mm-hmm so we
were constantly training we're constant
bringing the guys up to speed we also
want guys that are they are used to
handling weapons I don't think I've
talked to anybody who doesn't want to do
this job the problem is finding the
right combination of guys that we want
again listen we're talking about the
cannabis business right most people are
friendly and nice they don't want to be
met with a knuckle-dragger who's you
know got a gun slung around his neck and
talking about a but the next time we see
this guy we're gonna kill him they don't
want to hear that so you need that you
need that kind of that in between where
the guys happy and go-lucky but
understand say if things just off about
everything absolutely and if things go
left we're not looking for a gunfight
right we'd like to be able to
de-escalate and then we run into if I
can get the car and drive away again all
of our vehicles are up armored we have
that ability to drive away from a
situation providing that everybody's in
the truck we can just pull away so we
look at de-escalation it's a big part of
what we do across the board as well